good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe I believe in you and
I want to see that awesome thing that
you have inside you explode out into the
universe to have a major impact so to
help you on your journey today's message
is carry on over to you Conor McGregor
[Music]
I'm not going to stare at you stare at
your past and you'll end up staying
there it's okay to look back and admire
it but you carry on I'm not I'm not I'm
not in the business of staring staring
back at it you know what I mean I'm
getting lost back there it's people say
you can people say a loss can make a
break a fight that but trust me a win
can also make a break a fire because
they get comfortable with it with a win
people can get comfortable with it with
a win and and and slack off then
slack off on the train and slack off on
the diet they've won one they're winners
now that's not me you know you sleep on
a you sleep on a win and you'll wake up
with a loss so I just carry on keep
doing what I'm doing and that's why
these turnaround is so good for me
Vegas straight away the Fighting Irish
head to the fighting capital it's it's
perfect continue on this path the
freight train straight to the top so
don't you want to ask me the other day
what am I gonna do once I hit a million
subscribers what's the next goal for me
to go and crush my year and goal for
this year was to hit a million
subscribers it looks like that's gonna
happen and it's been nice having some
goals along the way when I first started
taking my youtube channel seriously I
was out in the agency there was somebody
else at the agency who was considered
the best on YouTube and so I I made it
my goal to pass that guy and I did and
then the next skill became okay I want
to get to a million subscribers and I
want to get there ahead of Gary
Vaynerchuk who's the other kind of big
guy in the entrepreneur space and it
looks like that's gonna happen
you know me and Gary Vee the gap is kind
of widening and I'm almost at a million
and so the next goal is what right that
was a question asked like okay you hit
that what's the next thing and I don't
really have one you know I guess the
next goal is gonna be 10 million that's
when you get the next plaque whatever
YouTube gives you
but that's not gonna happen in the next
you know unless things go insanely well
and there's nobody else ahead of me that
I really like I can't wait to go and
beat that person there's no enemy
there's no rival there's nobody else
that kind of chase down and for a lot of
people that's the end of their business
that's the end of their career it's like
if all you're doing is chasing the goal
and then you meet your goal then what do
you do next and I remember reading about
Ted Turner the billionaire Ted Turner
started CNN on the Atlanta Braves and
when his father reached his goal in his
business he shot himself he committed
suicide when Ted was in his early 20s I
believe and that's what happens
sometimes when you reach a goal you
reach your goal and then you're sad and
depressed and you don't know what to do
next until you set another goal that's
the cycle a lot of people go through
where for me it's gonna be great to hit
a million and I know I'm sure we'll try
to do some kind of celebration I'm not
huge on celebrations but you guys are
asking for it so I'll try to do
something but much more important than
having the next goal the next person to
be or the next milestone hit is carrying
on like I just like doing the work I
like making the videos better I wanted
to be better on camera I wanted to be
better at editing I want to you know
bring in better clips I want to launch
better series like I like the work of
the day to day stuff that happens in my
company and yes it's great to have these
milestones that we're reaching and yes I
have this bigger goal of helping a
billion entrepreneurs that huge goal
helps helps kiss keeps my mind set on
the big picture and what we're trying to
accomplish and then the little goals are
just the day-to-day stuff like I love
doing the day-to-day work and I think if
you don't love the process if you can't
carry on if you don't love the grind and
not every day is amazing and there's a
lot of crap that I have to deal with in
my business too I'm sure you guys have
it in your company that's the life of an
entrepreneur but net-like the work is
exciting is fun is is good I don't need
to have that big goal of who I'm gonna
beat next or what milestones a crush
through next it's also I don't really
care about celebrating the million that
that much because then it's not a big
deal like great I hit the million back
to work let's make it better this kid
going like cuz the work is what's
important every video is a celebration
like this video as a celebration this V
a celebration of all the work that's
come into it for me practicing being a
speaker for the research team pulling in
videos for the editing team processing
videos you know for our intros or X
shows the comments everything every
video we make I feel is a celebration it
says why I don't care so much about the
other celebrations of milestones but
that can be important for your team it
can be important for your customers and
so that's why we're still going to try
to do something and so it just encourage
you to think about that if you are only
focused on hitting that next goal
hitting that next revenue target but not
having a why and not caring about how
you go and do it it's like great yes
whatever it takes to go and do it but
like you got to enjoy that whatever it
takes or you're not gonna go and hit
that goal I'd encourage you to strongly
think about it if you're not having
success in your business if you're not
at the point where you want to be yet or
nowhere close take a look at the work
you're doing are you enjoying it
are you finding pleasure in it is each
work you create a celebration if only
for yourself like I look at what I just
made are you proud of the work that
you're doing or is it just feel like
you're grinding things out you don't
really care about it and just trying to
hit some kind of goal if you look at the
most successful people in the world they
carry on because they have an intense
love for what they're doing and yes
goals are important and yes goals are
driving them but they also enjoy the
day-to-day work of achieving that goal
so the question that today is I'm
curious even though I don't have a big
milestone to go and hit next or somebody
else to go and kind of compete against
if I had to who would you pick I'm
curious to hear your thoughts leave it
down in the comments below I also want
to give a quick shout out to Bobbi
O'Connor Bobbi thank you so much for
picking up a cup in my book your one
word really really means a lot to me and
I hope you're enjoying the read thank
you guys again for watching I hope you
have an amazing day I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is much
love and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of an espresso
expresso give me go
let's do the best we can with what we
have see we want to live in the now and
you see when you're down and out or
having difficulties your mind is working
very fast
not your being your mind is working very
fast and it's working off a lot of nails
from the past so a lot of experiences
from the past and worries of what may
happen in the future going through your
mind well if you could eliminate that by
saying okay there's nothing to do about
the past that's done yesterday's
newspapers can't change them and who
knows for sure was could have in the
future let's be here right now take what
resources we have right now act upon
them and act towards a good future goal
so you are actually going along the
street trading in you know bottles to
get a nickel apiece and in those days I
say actually was a second time oversell
so it's okay but in those days you got
two cents for a little pop bottle five
cents for a big one in every grocery
store in every liquor store you would
just bring them to and they'd give you
the money and you know you do what you
have to do exist of if times are lean
but alesis nation affords us that
opportunity if you know where you're at
well how can I best make it a survive
not oh poor me how do i entrench myself
for long term survivalists how do I
survive right now get myself to the next
step that's the attitude you have to so
many people in life we all know these
guys right they peaked at high school
they were prom king they were
quarterback of the team and they go
through life and you see them ten years
later and they're there sit at the bar
on a Tuesday with the male pattern
baldness and they're like bro back in
the day I was the man and they can't pay
their bills or driving a hooker and
they've turned into a basically a
complete accelerated version of
themselves which is a douche bag and
they haven't done anything with their
lives right and we see these people all
the time and the reason these people
don't progress is because they they
focus on the glory days they focus on
the things they have achieved in the
past and they don't let themselves work
towards a better future and guys you
have to be able to look at yourself and
be honest with yourself on this if this
is you you have to stop this behavior
okay when you focus on what you did last
year or what you did two years ago or
what you did last month or the award I
wanted the company function or the the
sales numbers that I hit and beat
everybody on this on the squad or
whatever when you focus on their guys
that is energy that you could be putting
into actually improving and focusing on
the task at hand which is today okay
champions don't soak in you know Kobe
Bryant doesn't sit there and talk about
how many MVPs he's won or how many
championships he's won know the up at
three o'clock in the morning
practicing every day why do you think he
is so great he's not great because he's
great he's great because he puts the
work in on a daily basis and he wins
every day problem in Western Europe
where we're failure is it's it's to
impossible to fail once you fail you can
never you can never start over I think
there's a there's an opposite version of
this in California where I think
sometimes people are a little bit too
facile about failure because I I think
it actually is always incredibly
damaging to people and if you work
really hard at something and it doesn't
work that's you know that's that's going
to be psychologically damaging you know
people have less confidence you know all
sorts of reasons why why that tends to
be that tends to be quite bad I think
that I think when people I don't think
there's that much you learned from
failure by the way because it's it's
typically over determined it's likewise
technology slowing down why did you fail
it's typically five separate reasons who
worked with the wrong people
the idea was bad the timing was wrong it
wasn't a monopoly the product didn't
work and okay next time I'm working with
different people you figure out one out
of the five things you're likely to fail
fail again so I think I think failure is
not something one can learn very much
from something that's sort of a myth
that I I would challenge but what I
think what I think you should do when
you when something goes badly wrong is
you just keep going you do something
else and you don't dwell on the past
ones volume you have the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details